אז המושג של פונדמנטליזם קשור בעצם
למושג של מדידה במכניקת הקוונטים
לפני שמכניקת הנקודה פותחה
הייתה ידועה בדרך כלל
אצל מדענים שאם יש לך מערכת שנמצאת
במצב מסוים
ואתה מבצע עליה מדידה, אתה הולך לקבל
תוצאה מוגדרת היטב
במכניקת הקוונטים זה כבר לא המצב, אפשר שיהיה לך
מערכת שנמצאת במצב מוגדר היטב לחלוטין
ובכל זאת כשאתה מבצע מדידות מסוימות
עליה, אתה יכול לקבל תוצאות אקראיות
אז כדי להמחיש את המושג הזה בצורה טובה יותר
אני צריך להביא את המושג של סופרפוזיציה
סופרפוזיציה היא מושג שהוא לא ייחודי לכאן
הוא מבוסס על הצגה של
כמה קומבינציות לינאריות של מצבים
בו-זמנית, ואפשר לחשוב על זה
למשל כמו גל רדיו שנושא
תדרים שונים רבים, אין שום דבר
בדרישה אנושית בנוגע לזה
מה שנותן את הטעם הקוונטי לסופרפוזיציה הוא
עצם מדידת המערכת
אז אני אמחיש עם דוגמה
דמיין שיש לך מערכת של חיצים
ואתה מכין את המערכת
כך שכל החיצים מצביעים שמאלה
ואז אתה הולך ו
שואל את המערכת את השאלה: אתה למעלה או למטה?
וכל חץ, כי החיצים מצביעים שמאלה, ניתן
לבטא ולתאר
כסופרפוזיציה לינארית בין
למעלה ולמטה, תקבל
תוצאות של חמישים אחוז למעלה
וחמישים אחוז למטה כשאתה שואל האם אתה פתוח
אתה מקבל את התוצאה הזו מהמערכת
ואז אתה יכול להכין
מצב שונה של המערכת שבו יש
חצי מהחיצים מצביעים למעלה וחצי
מצביעים למטה ואתה שואל את אותה שאלה
ואתה מקבל את אותה תוצאה
אלה שתי מערכות שונות מאוד
ויש לך את המידע הזה
עכשיו, במשך זמן רב
איך אפשר לקבוע מה ההבדל הוא
המצבים שונים מאוד
כי במקרה הראשון הכנת את המערכת ב
מצב טהור, ויש שאלה שאתה
יכול לשאול את המערכת שתיתן לך תוצאה דטרמיניסטית
ולא אקראית, והשאלה הזו היא: שמאל או ימין?
זה יגיד לך מאה אחוז שמאלה
במקרה השני אין שאלה שאתה יכול לשאול
שתיתן לך מאה אחוז, כי זה תערובת
תוצאה קבועה, כי זו תערובת
אז אם אתה שואל שמאל או ימין
זה הולך להיות אקראי, כי חציים למעלה
וחציים למטה, אם אתה שואל למעלה או למטה
אותו דבר, זה הולך להיות חמישים אחוז
איך זה קשור לאקראיות הקוונטית?
אז אפשר לדמיין שזה
דומה להטלת מטבע, זה הולך להיות עץ או פלי
אבל זה לא כמו להטיל מטבע בכלל
כי כשאתה זורק מטבע
הסיבה היחידה שאתה לא יודע את התוצאה שתקבל
היא שאתה לא יודע
את האנרגיה שבה הטלת את המטבע, את זווית המומנטום
ואת התנאים הסביבתיים בחדר
וכן הלאה, אז אם ידעת את כל אלה
המשתנים, יכולת לנבא עץ או פלי
אלה משתנים שמוסתרים מהצופה
ובמשך שנים רבות מדענים חשבו שיש
משתנים דומים במכניקת הקוונטים שיתגלו
ויראו את עצמם כאקראיות
וזה לא היה עד ל
העבודה הסמינלית של John Bell בשנות השישים שהראתה
שזה לא המצב
ועכשיו כל פיזיקאי
מודה שאין משתנים נסתרים
שתואמים למכניקת הקוונטים
אז זה ממש נכון שכשאתה מודד מערכת
הטבע חושף תוצאה
לא משנה כמה זמן אני חושב על זה, זה
פשוט מדהים